em toda a diferença toda história pode
ser contada o mundo repleto de histórias
narrativas de múltiplas
e nas artes na literatura na música no
cinema muitas histórias são contadas
é mas se você olhar para mim
e você pode até um perceber de início
É mas você vai ver a minha história
simbolizada na minha pele e
É sim a minha história contada pelo
vitiligo
e eu te ligo são essas manchas que eu
tenho no corpo
e ela simbolizam as minhas emoções
é o que eu vivi o que eu senti ao longo
do percurso da vida e hoje eu tô aqui
para contar um pouco delas para vocês
Ah eu convido com vitiligo desde muito
novo desde os 4 anos mais ou menos desde
garoto eu já tive que enfrentar algumas
batalhas aos 3 anos eu desenvolvi
síndrome de Kawasaki tive que ser
internado para a retirada de um rim e
logo após esses eventos difíceis o
vitiligo nasceu em mim o vitiligo já
nasceu como símbolo como marca de
Vitória acho que eu precisei vencer
é por isso que eu digo que o verde Lima
ele ele simboliza em mim não as minhas
dores nos mostrarmos as minhas as minhas
coisas negativas mas são marcas das
Vitórias que eu precisei vencer das
lutas que eu precisei vencer vai estar
aqui ó
e eu te ligo para mim simboliza as
marcas da nossa história
E logo na infância eu percebi que tem
Vitiligo poderia me trazer algumas
coisas boas na escola eu percebi que as
pessoas que se aproximavam de mim que
estavam mais próximos quero mais
presente na minha vida não eram pessoas
que eram carregados de chegue mas não
eram pessoas que me caçoavam o vi o
vitiligo como algo ruim como algo
estranho os meus amigos reais nunca me
discriminavam então desde novo comecei a
perceber que o 20 livre poderia
funcionar com uma espécie de armaduras
armaduras que me afastava das pessoas
ruins
é mas demorou um tempo para poder olhar
o vitiligo desse modo
o fio longo e árduo processo até eu
pensar o vitiligo como eu penso hoje
é isso processo teve como
a ajuda e ferramenta primordial arte a
música na minha vida a partir da música
da forma como eu me relacionava ele
expressava pela música pelo meio
instrumento pelas relações sociais que
em volta da arte e o me conectar com as
pessoas não baseado em estímulos eu
aparência as estéticas para determinadas
eu me relacionar com as pessoas a partir
do meu som do fazer um scalpe isso foi o
grande Elo importante da arte na minha
vida
e percebeu que tio como uma
a expressão as minhas emoções
e é uma ideia importante é uma ideia que
vai contra
Olá tudo a ideia comum que se tem a
respeito do Vitiligo
e eu nascir uma época em que o vitiligo
não estava nas mídias
eu não estava exposto
se você teve eu te ligo realmente
classificado pela leitura e literatura
médica com uma doença com mal que deve
ser curado com uma o que deve ser
o apagado de você é
e antes de vir para cá
e eu fui na internet Entrei numa
comunidade enorme de pessoas que têm que
te ligo essa comunidade é muito famosa e
tem muita gente com que te levar essa
comunidade eu não sei a seguinte
pergunta o que o vitiligo é significa na
vida de vocês
Oi e para minha surpresa não né nenhuma
ou quase nenhuma mensagem foi de
potência
a enxergar o vitiligo como
possibilidades
e as mensagens são carregadas de dor e
sofrimento As pessoas dizem que o
vitiligo é detalhes em segurança é
Olá tudo tipo sentimento negativo
e aquilo me fez refletir
o que as pessoas ainda não passaram por
esse processo de ressignificação
bom e falar de como é esse processo eu
acho cada vez mais importante ele não
acontece de um dia para noite nem de um
dia para o outro
e ele demanda tempo
bom e muita persistência e até coragem
apoderamento
e quando a pessoa adquire te ligo você
percebe o nascimento das manchas
inicialmente se tem uma
é uma espécie de choque
e se a senhora me espelho e percebe que
a sua imagem já não é mais aquela que
era no outro dia cê imagem acaba se
transformando mudando então Acontece uma
espécie de crise de identidade
bom então a pessoa que convive com
vitiligo ela tem que se ver do dia para
a noite de uma outra forma
o e as e esse choque acaba gerando a
necessidade a busca pelo tratamento você
você entra nessa comunidade As perguntas
são todas ligadas a isso como como mudar
com o Qual remédio é bom qual remédio é
isso mas você me pergunta porque curar o
vitiligo é
o vitiligo não dói
e no arde não coça não é contagioso
e somente
e a sua beleza contagiosa
e hoje eu olho e te ligo com o símbolo
como expressão da diversidade
e como expressão da multiplicidade de
corpos
Ah e assim que este livro deve ser visto
e como arte como expressão máxima das
minhas emoções
e demorou um tempo para eu te entender
ele desse modo Demorou não foi do dia
para noite como digo E isso aconteceu
primeiro pela música o modo como
expressava enquanto música pouco
importava se eu tinha Vitiligo não
queria ter um são bonito queria estar
com as minhas diferenças queria ouvir
boas músicas e tocar boas música está
com os meus amigos como Uganda de outras
formas de expressão mas chegou um
momento que na minha na minha evolução
enquanto o homem precisei me expressar e
me constituir de um modo mais Global
precisei realmente não colocar só a arte
na frente nas relações precisei me
empodera encontra um homem encontro
pessoa que se achava bonita imagina sou
carioca moro no Rio de Janeiro e Janeiro
a cidade super Praiana os corpos simples
estão expostas na praia e
bom e ficou um mês que eu fui não um
povo precisa ter vergonha de ir na praia
de botar uma sunga aqui vai aparecer
essa mancha assim muitas pessoas que têm
que te ligo deve estar se sentindo que
já passaram por esse tipo de situação e
isso é uma coisa muito comum em mim mas
chega um momento que eu precisei
realmente me poderá então melhor no
espelho e falar não tem coragem de
realmente tirar a camisa na praia de me
sentir bonita eu comecei a malhar
comecei a me cuidar comecei sabe
realmente a enfrentar os meus medos e
foi nesse momento aqui o vitiligo para
mim ele começou a dar uma outra
perspectiva outra potência
e foi quando de repente Olha a arte mais
uma vez um fotógrafo me chamou para um
ensaio fotográfico
Oi e a partir desse ensaio
e eu pude me ver
é de uma outra forma
e eu pude ver o meu vitiligos as minhas
manchas
e como arte como beleza
e o desenho que elas formavam Cada
pessoa tem um vestido único Cada pessoa
tem uma forma
e eu te ligo ele nasce na nossa pele
como expressão cada tipo de Vitiligo têm
o seu desenho tenso a sua o seu
movimento ninguém tem um vestido igual
outro isso já reforça uma importante
ideia de identidade de marca
bom e depois a gente sai quando eu
percebi que Nossa sua bonito isso né vou
até que é legal aí eu comecei a postar
foto de cinco mais assiduamente
assiduamente assim na nas redes sociais
E aí me convidaram para uma campanha de
conscientização e de Vitiligo aqui em
São Paulo
e não eu vim para São Paulo fiz esse
ensaio comecei a postar fotos na
internet do meu dia a dia do meu
cotidiano assumindo em realmente Esconda
o meu corpo convite livro
e foi quando eu comecei a perceber que
eu não estava sozinho existia uma grande
importante rede de pessoas que
conviveram com 20 negro
o que Muitas delas começaram a certa
forma a se inspirar
e porquê
e a inspiração é uma rede a gente vê uma
outra pessoa na nossa situação parecida
com a nós e uma pessoa esperando a outra
Ah e quando eu percebi que o vitiligo é
e não era algo devido individualizado
Realmente são em mim mas que existe uma
perspectiva de comunidade
e eu percebi que o meu corpo ele não era
só uma expressão individual ele é um
símbolo de diversidade símbolo de uma
causa e foi quando uma agência de São
Paulo começou
não vai me convidar para poder atuar
como modelo agora tu imagina eu já
em muitas cidades para trabalhar como
modelo já tinha minha carreira enquanto
música
é mas eu aceitei aceitei e comecei a
trabalhar com publicidade com moda
que atuem em clipes de importantes
cantores da música pop
eu e o meu corpo começou a ser exposta
mas ser exposto como símbolo
e com o símbolo da diversidade com o
símbolo de potência
e essa minha história é
é contada na pele as minhas emoções
o constituídas nas minhas manchas não
nas minhas nuvens não as minhas 500 mais
das minhas manchas vitiligos o vitiligo
essa mancha ela é minha potência meu
orgulha
Oi e essa ideia é me importa
e era importante ser disseminada
é porque como ver com vitiligo é
e é Minha Porção
Esse é o que o
eu sempre fui
a e tá podendo contar aviso para vocês
essa minha vivência
e é muito importante para mim mais
importante para quem convive com
vitiligo
é porque muitas pessoas ainda estão no
livro da dor no livro do sofrimento mas
quando você significa quando você muda
essa percepção quando você encaro eu te
ligo quanto beleza que o outro Art
e o vitiligo se torna arte no corpo arte
na pele e viva como mestre Pixinguinha
e falou vou vivendo
E aí
[Música]
G1
E aí
[Aplausos]